Google's very interested in improving the speed of the Web.
Because the Web is the most important platform of our time.
And by making the Web better and faster,...
...we not only make Google applications better...
...but in fact, all the applications users know and love.
We also believe that people are using the Web more and more as a place to read, view videos...
In order for that information to be useful,...
...we need to make sure that it is delivered in a timely fashion.
You know, I think we're just at the beginning of how fast we can make the Web.
It's hard for us to imagine the improvements that we've made just in the last 15 years,...
...if you think about how slow the Web was when it initially started...
...and how far we've come.
Larry Page expressed a vision of being able to go from Web page to Web page...
...as quickly as you could turn the pages in a glossy magazine.
Uploading pictures, watching high-definition movies,...
...running very complex Javascript-based apps.
All those things can and should be instantaneous in the future.